The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's go
back to our discussion
of spectral broadening.
And what I started
to derive for you
is perturbation theory of
spectral broadening, which
is a very general framework.
I like it, because
it really provides
you insight into
spectral broadening.
But I will also hope it
provides new insight for you
for time-dependent perturbation
theory [INAUDIBLE].
So what we did in
this lecture is
we pretty much did standard
type perturbation theory.
We just did it by
assuming that we
have a general
time-dependent perturbation.
I'm not yet telling you what the
time-dependent perturbation is.
It has actually fluctuating.
It has inhomogeneous.
It has everything in
it which will later
lead to line-broadening
line shifts.
And the important quantity which
is now describing everything
we are interested
is the correlation
function between the
perturbation at time t
pi and t.
And we call this
correlation function G.
And it is either the
correlation function G of t,
or it's Fourier
transform, which tells us
what the excitation
rate of the system is.
I want to give you sort
of two summaries now.
And they're both general
to perturbation theory.
But I have to say, I
myself learned something
about time evolution of quantum
systems from those examples.
So what we get is a
very generic thing,
that when we look
at the probability
to be in the final state,
the amplitude V of t squared,
we start out quadratic, a very
general behavior of any quantum
system, because your linear
equation, which linearly
puts amplitude into the
excited state is quadratic.
And also, this is the beginning
of a Rabi oscillation.
The Rabi oscillation
starts out with 0 slope.
But then you have some
de-coherence type.
The fields are no longer driving
the system in a coherent way.
And then that's where we
enter the regime of Fermi's
golden rule, the probability
to be in the excited state
only goes linear.
And this is when we
have rate equations.
Let me sort of show how it
comes about in equations,
which I think is really nice.
The differential equations
is that in a time delta t,
we add amplitude delta
t to the excited state.
And so the amplitude
we build up is--
I may have called an h bar.
Or maybe I measured
[INAUDIBLE] frequency units.
It's just the matrix
element times delta t.
And we usually call
the matrix element
the Rabi frequency over 2.
So you should think
about it, that we
add sort of this amplitude.
And as long as we
are coherent, I
have to take the amplitude
1/2 the Rabi frequency delta,
then square it.
And here, you get the
quadratic behavior.
This behavior you also have
constructive interference.
All those delta [INAUDIBLE] are
added in a phase-coherent way.
But this behavior ends, of
course, at the coherence time.
Let me just get my notes.
So when the time becomes
comparable to the coherence
time, then we are adding
amplitude not as constructive
interference-- we are
adding B squared [INAUDIBLE]
becomes sort of a
[INAUDIBLE], and we
add things in quadrature.
So what happens is at
the coherence time,
we have created
an amplitude which
is given by this expression.
But now if time goes by,
we add in quadrature t
over tc chunks of that.
So therefore, our B square,
which we build up with time,
is linear in time
and is omega Rabi
squared over 4, the matrix
element times the coherence
time tc.
And this here now is our
rate in the rate equation.
And this is also what
we exactly got out
of the correlation
function formalism.
So this is how you
should think about it.
You go from constructive
interference
in amplitude and adding
things in quadrature.
Let me maybe add one more
discussion to it, which I hope
will help you to
see the big picture.
We have a matrix
element V. And if I just
ask you, think about
Fermi's golden rule,
you would find out
that the rate is
V square times the density
of states at the resonance.
And sometimes instead of
the density of states,
you write a delta function,
which is just a placeholder
that you should do
an energy integral.
And then you get the
density of states.
OK.
So this is sort of
Fermi's golden rule,
and it should be old hat to you.
But what I told you now is
that what is involved here
from the time integration is the
correlation function, V of 0,
V of t as two different types.
But then because of
the type integration
of Schrodinger's equation,
we had a time integral dt.
But V of 0, V of t, remember,
we have a correlation
between the field V of 0.
And then it decays with time.
This here can be written
V of 0 squared times
the correlation time tau c.
So therefore, the
correlation function,
it's a general formalism.
It allows us to deal with
all time dependencies.
But in essence, the
time-integrated correlation
function is nothing
else than your operator,
your perturbation
operator, time t
equals 0 squared times
the correlation time.
And the correlation time, the
inverse of the correlation
time, is the spectral
widths of your drive field.
And this is what
the spectral widths
is in Fermi's golden rule.
On the other hand, if you do
the integration V of t dt,
think about it as
Fourier transform,
it gives us actually
some V of omega.
It gives us the
Fourier transform.
Well, I see it omega.
If you just do V of t
dt, you get the Fourier
transform at 0 frequency.
But if you look
through the derivation
we did that was an
e to the i omega
resonant term, which we
were just spitting out.
So we have sort of shifted
the origin of frequency.
So therefore, the
Fourier transform,
if I correct for this just
offset infrequency which
I introduced for
simplicity, this
is nothing else than asking
whether the drive field has
a Fourier component
which can resonate
the drive to transition.
And we talked last class
about the convolution.
This gives actually
the power spectrum.
It keeps the Fourier
transform of it squared.
But the power spectrum is, of
course-- when you take a field
and fully analyze
it, [INAUDIBLE]
is the power spectrum, the whole
power and the whole intensity
of your laser, of your
field is spread out
over the banquets of the source.
So when you say, the power
spectrum, the power spectrum
is automatically intensity
divided by spectral widths.
And that's where
the delta function
and the spectral widths in the
normal formulation of Fermi's
golden rule come in.
So I'm just emphasizing
I haven't really
done anything new than just
giving you a general notation.
And I would actually
say-- whenever
you were asking yourself
about Fermi's golden rule,
this is the full [INAUDIBLE].
This is about a fully
time-dependent arbitrary time
field.
And you realize, what was
re-squaring Fermi's golden rule
is actually just
the simple case,
the more general case--
and the more general case
is it's a correlation
or it's a power spectrum
which creates the rate
in Fermi's golden rule.
Any questions about that?
OK.
So we have this
powerful formalism.
So all we have to do is when
we want to understand what
is the rate and
the spectral widths
of the spectroscopic
features is we
have to understand what is
the field driving the atom.
And then we take the
Fourier transform,
or we figure out what
the correlation is.
We take V of 0 squared
times the correlation time,
and we know what the rate is.
And this will allow
us major insight
into spectral broadening.
OK.
But after introducing
that in general,
I think it's time
for a simple example.
And as a simple
example, I just thought
I'd show you how we get
the natural line widths.
And of course, the
natural line widths--
I've mentioned several times,
we need Optical Bloch equations.
We have to really
kind of capture
the interplay between
the coherent drive
of the atom and the
spontaneous decay.
But just
phenomenologically, if I
say the excited state has a
decay rate of gamma over 2,
I mentioned it
before, we can capture
some aspects of
spontaneous decay.
And that means now,
remember, our spectral widths
comes from the correlation
function of the matrix element.
And now the operator
is constant,
but the state is decaying.
So therefore, the matrix element
has this exponentially decaying
function.
And if you then ask,
what is the correlation
function at time 0 and
time tau, we get this.
Of course, the Fourier transform
of an exponentially decaying
function is a Lorentian.
And I've shown you now with a
different formalism that yes,
if you have dampening in the
excited state, for instance,
you do spontaneous decay,
we get the Lorentian.
Of course, we know there should
be power broadening, too.
But of course, don't
expect power broadening
from a perturbative approach,
because a perturbative approach
is only valid when we
have weak drive fields.
Questions?
OK.
So now I want to-- after
this simple example,
I want to explain to
you Doppler broadening.
I know I will
present it in a way
and draw some conclusions
which are usually not done
in the normal presentation
of Doppler broadening.
So what we have to bring in now
is that we have moving atoms.
That's what Doppler
broadening is about.
We drive the field with
an electromagnetic wave.
And we have usually ignored
the spatial dependence,
assuming the atom was
clamped down in c equals 0.
But now we have to
allow for motion.
So the relevant matrix
element for which
we want to calculate
the correlation function
has now a spatial dependence.
And our correlation
function, G of ba,
involves now-- I call
the Rabi frequency now
x for, well, simplicity
of-- [INAUDIBLE]
took this material,
because they use it.
OK.
So now we have the
correlation function.
We have the temporal
part, t prime minus t.
But then we have a spatial part.
And this is now
the new part which
has to account for that the
atom is moving from one position
to another one.
And when we calculate
the correlation function,
we have to average
now over the velocity
distribution of the atom.
So this new part, which will
account for Doppler broadening,
I called this part I. And
z of t prime minus z of t
is simply the velocity
of the atom times tau.
Tau is t prime minus t.
So atoms move by that.
And v is the z component
of the velocity.
So now we have to
calculate that.
And of course, we
assume that we have
a Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution.
We assume a Maxwell-Boltzmann
And then our
expression I, we have
to convolute-- we have
this term, e to the kv tau.
But now we have to
convolute it with
the one-dimensional
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution,
where alpha is the
most probable velocity.
And since the velocity
distribution is normalized,
we have this p [? vector. ?]
Alpha is the most probable
speed, and mu is the mass
of the-- sorry, it's not mu,
it's M. And M is the
mass of the atom.
This integral, of course,
can easily be solved.
And we find that provides--
[INAUDIBLE] Gaussian envelope
with time tau, so it's
exponential-decayed with time
tau.
And our rate, which
is the matrix element,
involves now the
temporal integral over--
let me just scroll up.
In our correlation function,
we had a temporal part
and a spatial part.
And the rate-- this was
Fermi's golden rule--
is the time we've taken over
the correlation function.
So therefore, we have the
exponential [? vector ?]
in time.
After convolution with the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution,
we have this exponentially
decaying term.
And the result of
that is, well, hooray,
we have re-derived
the Gaussian profile
for a Doppler broad light.
OK.
But yes, we want to look at
this result with some new eyes,
because until now,
you would have said,
OK, that's really trivial.
Each atom has a velocity.
Galilean transformation
into the moving frame
means the frequency has shifted,
and everything falls together.
And yes, that's one
way to look at it.
In inhomogeneous broadening,
each atom has its own velocity.
But now we want to look
at it from the viewpoint
of a correlation function
describing the whole system.
So we had calculated this
correlation function,
which the atomic
ensemble experiences.
And this correlation
function here
decays as a function of time.
And it decays with a
characteristic time.
Tau c, which is 1 over k alpha.
And this is nothing else than
the reduced wavelengths lambda
bar divided by the
most probable velocity.
OK.
So we want to relate
the line widths
to some form of coherence.
And what we realize
is the coherence
time of the correlation
function, which needs Doppler
broadening, is the time it takes
an atom with the most probably
velocity to move one wavelength.
But wait.
What we have is, in the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution,
the most probably
velocity is also
the widths of the velocities.
So therefore, what we can say
is, if all the atoms would
start at one position, after
the correlation time tc,
the atoms have spread
out over one wavelength.
So therefore, the
correlation time
tells us how long is the whole
ensemble driven coherently.
But once the atoms,
due to their motion,
spread out compared to
their initial position,
while extra
wavelengths, each atom
experiences now a different
phase of the drive field.
And that sets a limit
to the coherence.
And this is the point where
when we ask how many atoms
are getting excited, we
can no longer add amplitude
in a constructive, linear way.
We are adding amplitudes
in quadrature.
And this is exactly
what I explained to you
at the beginning
of this lecture.
So let me just summarize it.
Alpha is the thermal
spread of velocities.
So the keyword is here.
Atoms, in a random way,
spread out by lambda
in the coherence time tc.
Well, a question which should
come to your mind is now,
but what happens when the atoms
are in an atom [INAUDIBLE]
and they cannot spread out?
That's what you want to
discuss in a few minutes.
But before I do
that, let me give you
another interpretation,
which is helpful.
You can regard-- if you
have a thermal ensemble,
you can say, OK, I have a box.
Each atom is a plain wave
with a perfect velocity,
and now an ensemble of that.
But very often, especially
if you do localized physics,
you want to regard each
atom as a wave packet.
And if you want to use
a localized description
of your gas, where
atoms are wave packets,
then you assume, in a
consistent description,
that the atoms are spread out
due to the momentum spread
in the Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution.
This is nothing else
than h bar divided
by the mass and the most
[INAUDIBLE] velocity.
And this is foregoing
[? vectors ?]
on the order of unity, nothing
else than the thermal de
Broglie wavelengths.
OK.
So now we have the
picture that the atom
is a wave packet in
the ground state.
But now we excite
it with a laser.
Well, if we excite it with a
laser, part of the wave packet
goes to the excited state.
But the atoms in
the excited state,
because they have absorbed the
photon recall of the photon,
are now moving away
from the ground state
part of the wave packet,
with the recall velocity,
with this h bar k over M.
So if I regard
the atom as a wave
packet, the natural
question is, when
does the ground state
of the wave packet
lose overlap with the excited
state part of the wave packet?
Lost overlap after time--
well, I derive it for you.
But it can only be
the coherence time.
So the time is the
size of the wave packet
divided by the recall velocity.
The mass cancels out.
H bar cancels out.
And this is 1 over k alpha.
And this was exactly
our coherence time.
So therefore, when
I'm telling you
you should understand
this picture,
Doppler broadening is a loss
of coherence for the ensemble.
You have now two
ways to describe it.
One is you can say, in a
more quantum mechanical way,
after the coherence
time, the recall velocity
has separated the
grounded, excited part
of your wave packet.
Or you can say, when the
atoms in the ensemble
have a velocity
spread of alpha, then
they have spread out by
the optical wavelengths.
So these are two
equivalent picture
to understand why this ensemble
is no longer coherently driven.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in both
of the curves, like, why is,
in the first picture, the
optical wavelength not
relevant; in the second one,
[INAUDIBLE] not relevant?
[INAUDIBLE] distance.
PROFESSOR: Well, because these
are two different pictures,
but the results agree.
I mean, the wavelength comes
into the picture with the wave
packets through the
recall velocity,
because the recall
velocity is h bar k over M,
and k is the
inverse wavelengths.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But when we write delta t
there, we write [INAUDIBLE]
the wavelengths off
the packet here,
and we could have also
just thought of it as,
when does the atomic
ensemble become
bigger than the optical rate?
But here, we are [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I think
for consistency-- I'll
give you a quick answer.
I should think about it
longer, but what we usually
assume when we describe
atoms by wave packets,
we assume the atoms
are not cooled
below the so-called
recoil limit.
So we assume that the thermal
de Broglie wavelengths
is shorter than the
optical wavelengths.
And so then if you would
say, you would expect also
that there would be something
happening when the wave
packet spreads out by
an optical wavelength,
I want to think about it more.
But the quick answer
is, just assume
what is usually the
semi-classical limit
of these kind of
pictures, where we
assume that we have a hierarchy
that the thermal de Broglie
wavelength is much larger
than the size of the atoms
but smaller than the
optical wavelengths.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
PROFESSOR: A few
things happen, really,
in intuitive pictures
when you cool atoms
before the recoil limit.
OK.
There's one reason why I would
like to express it to you.
Armed with that knowledge,
if I would now ask you--
you have a trapped
Bose-Einstein condensate,
and you take the spectrum.
What is the Doppler
widths of the spectrum
of a Bose-Einstein condensate?
[INAUDIBLE] extra
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
No.
The condensate is different.
It's in one quantum state.
But now you can
choose your picture.
One picture you can take is
you can say, the de Broglie
wavelengths here has to be--
you know, the wave packet loses
overlap when the
excited state moves
one de Broglie wavelength.
But the condensate
is fully coherent.
So you would now say,
maybe I should think about
if-- if the
condensate part of it
is coupled to the excited
state, and with a recoil,
the excited state
component has moved
the size of the condensate,
replacing the de Broglie
wavelengths by the
size of the condensate.
And this is a correct answer.
You would then find out
what is, quotation mark,
the Doppler broadening
of a condensate.
Of course, you could
have also said,
the condensate is
a certain size,
h bar divided by the size is
the momentum spread if you
do Heisenberg's
uncertainty relation.
And now I plug in
this momentum spread
into a formula for the
Doppler broadening.
And you would get
the same result.
But especially when you think
in terms of a coherent wave
function, this picture of losing
overlap between the two parts
of the wave packets is very
intuitive, very useful.
And it actually guided
a lot of our intuition
when we looked at the
limitations of super radians
and optical spectroscopy with
Bose-Einstein condensates.
Any questions?
OK.
So now we are ready to
take it to the next level.
When I told you that
the spectral widths
is the inverse of
the coherence time.
And one way to think
about the coherence time
is that the particles spread
out over one wavelength.
So if you take this
thought seriously and say,
what happens if I confine atoms
in a container or an atom trap
to less than the
optical wavelengths,
then you would
say, they can never
spread out by an
optical wavelength.
Does it mean that the
coherence time is now infinite
and that we can do spectroscopy,
which is no longer affected
in any way by
Doppler broadening.
Well, what I just
motivated in words
is the so-called Lamb-Dicke
limit of tight confinement.
And as I want to show
you now, yes indeed,
you have a very,
very sharp line which
is not broadened by
Doppler broadening, which
is not shifted by
the recoil shift.
It's really the unperturbed
line of the atom which
can be probed by confining
the atoms to less
than a wavelength.
So therefore, let's
now discuss the line
shape of confined particles.
So what I want to
present you now
is we have particles trapped
in a harmonic oscillator.
And in one limit, which
I want to explain you,
we should just find the normal
Gaussian Doppler profile
which we have
obtained for free gas.
This must be the limit when
the [INAUDIBLE] confinement is
very weak.
But for tight confinement,
we should actually find,
unless we assume other
means of line broadening,
a delta function
spectral feature.
And I will explain to
you that this is actually
the same as the
Mossbauer effect.
It's a Mossbauer line
due to the confinement.
So therefore, to have
trapped particles
allows us to go to the
ultimate limit in precision
spectroscopy.
What happens when you
have trapped particles--
the Mossbauer effect,
which I mentioned,
or simply the effect of
confinement-- in other words,
the trapping potential
is completely
eliminating the Doppler effect.
But I want to be specific.
It only eliminates the
first-order Doppler effect.
Everything I just did with
the correlation function
assumed first-order
Doppler effect.
If you want to get rid of the
second-order Doppler effect,
then you need some
form of proving.
But usually, when
you do experiments
with trapped particles, you
do confinement and cooling
at the same time.
OK.
Let me start out with
very basic things.
So let's talk about the spectrum
of an oscillating emitter.
If we have an atom, it undergoes
a transition from excited state
b to excited state a,
this is an internal state.
But now we want
to include motion.
And we have to include the
external degree of freedom.
And for our discussion right
now, the external degree
of freedom is [INAUDIBLE]
trapping potential.
So now we look at the
combined system, combined--
we can say Hubert
space, which combines
external and internal motion.
And of course, the external
motion is now quantized.
I can't assume, but it doesn't
really add anything to it
at this point-- that
the trap frequency
and the ground and excited
state are different.
I simply assume that
the trap frequency omega
trap is the same.
This, of course, is excellently
fulfilled in ion traps.
If you reduce spectroscopy of
neutral atoms in a dipole trap,
of course, the ground
and excited state
may experience a
different AC stark shift.
And then you have to account
for two different frequencies.
But let me just make this
simplifying assumption.
So if you assume that
an atom emits radiation,
it will, for energy
conservation,
emit at the electronic energy.
But then there is an extra
term, which, in general, is
the energy of the
external motion,
or the trapping potential
for the initial state
minus the final state.
And if we now make our
simplifying assumption
that everything is harmonic,
that hyper-potential
is harmonic, and the
trapping frequency
is the same in the excited
state and the ground state,
we simply have the electronic
energy plus n quanta--
n is the change of the number of
quanta of the harmonic motion.
I want to point out,
it looks so trivial.
But you should at least
think for a second
about this statement, that this
formula includes the Doppler
shift and the recoil shift.
And of course, this is trivial,
because we are talking here
about the total energy
of the external state,
the total energy of the final
state after photon emission.
And the energy and
the trapping potential
includes all the kinetic
energy of the particle, which
includes whatever comes
from [INAUDIBLE] velocity
or from the motion of the atom.
So therefore, we obtain what is
called the sideband spectrum.
I'll just show you
a stick diagram.
Here is the
electronic transition.
And then we have sidebands.
And the spacing
of those sidebands
is nothing else than the
harmonic oscillator frequency.
Any questions?
At that level, I want
you to appreciate
that this is radically different
from Doppler broadening.
There is no Doppler broadening.
By fully quantizing the motion
in the harmonic oscillator,
we obtain a discrete spectrum.
And what I want to show
you is when we calculate
the intensity in the peak
for strong confinement,
almost all of the intensity's
in the central peak.
And therefore, there is
no Doppler broadening.
But I want to later
show you how we
can go from the discrete
spectrum back to the Doppler
broadening which we just
described in free space.
You should say, well, but
the motion, the recall,
it must come in.
Where is it?
Well, it's not in
this stick diagram.
But the sticks are
the only possibilities
for the possible photon
frequencies or photon energies.
But the question is,
what is the amplitude?
What is the probability
that this will happen?
And you already see
where I'm aiming to.
In the limit that we
have many, many sticks
and we are not
resolving the sticks,
we will get back to them in the
standard Doppler broadening.
So the big question is, how
many of those sticks do we have?
Are we in the limit where
things are heavily discrete?
This is our new limit?
Or do we have
many, many of them?
So therefore, the recoil
and the velocity, they
really enter when we
calculate the intensity.
And whatever our formulation
is with Fermi's golden rule,
the rate is proportional
to the relevant matrix
element squared.
And now I want to show you
how we calculate those matrix
element.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE: But is it true
that each of these sticks
has the intrinsic line
width of the atom?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
We come to that
in a few minutes.
I ignore here the
spontaneous broadening just
for pedagogical reasons.
But a little bit
later, I will-- I first
want to sort of discuss
the number of sticks.
Do we have a few?
This is sort of new, then
we have only few sidebands,
and we have the
Mossbauer effect.
If we have many, that's sort
of more the continuum, which
we described with the classical
velocity distribution.
That's my message number one.
But then the next message
is, do we resolve the sticks?
Do we have resolved
sidebands or not?
And for that, the criterion
is, is the natural line widths
large or smaller than
the sideband spacing?
It's not just one parameter;
there are two parameters.
One is which will be the
Lamb-Dicke parameter--
how many sticks do we have?
And the second question is,
do we resolve the sticks?
And you can say there are
four different regimes,
you know-- yes or no for
question one, or yes or no
for questions two.
Other questions?
OK.
So the rate is proportional
to the matrix element squared.
And yes, we have all kind of
the matrix elements involving
the internal degree.
But the new thing is
the matrix element
for the center of mass wave
function of the atom, which
is-- you can see just
the emission where
the polynomials of the
harmonic oscillator.
So we have the eigen functions
for the harmonic oscillator
between initial and final state.
And what acts on the only part
of the electromagnetic field
operator, which acts on
the position of the atom,
is this term, e
to the minus ikr.
OK.
I mentioned already
that the new regime
is that the
confinement is tight.
So let's just look
at this situation.
When kr is much
smaller than 1, then we
can expand this exponential
into 1 minus ikr.
And now I want to remind
you that the position
operator, when we treat
the harmonic oscillator,
is nothing else than
a plus a dagger.
So therefore, if kr is
small and therefore we
can do the first-order expansion
of e to the ikr, our spectrum,
our operator is here-- 1 minus
e [? vector ?] a plus a dagger.
And therefore, the
only possible sidebands
are the one where the
change in harmonic
oscillator quantum number
is plus or minus 1.
So we are already
obtaining the result,
which is called the
Lamb-Dicke limit when
kr is much smaller than 1,
that we have a strong carrier.
We have only sticks-- the
delta n equals plus, minus 1.
And the intensity in
each of those sticks
is actually proportional
to k squared r squared,
which is nothing else than
the square of the extension
of the atomic wave function.
And k is 1 over lambda
bar squared, divided
by the optical
wavelengths we get.
So we see already-- I mean,
without any major formalism
or mathematical
tools-- what happens
in the limit of
tight confinement.
The spectrum of confined
particles is eclectic,
the spontaneous line widths.
A delta function without
any Doppler shift,
without any recoil shift, right
at the resonance frequency,
electronic frequency
of the atom.
The only thing
which is reminiscent
of the motional
degree of freedom
are those small satellites.
But their intensity goes
to 0 with the extension
squared over lambda squared.
So therefore, if you
confine the particle
to less than an
optical wavelength,
the older picture I told
you, it can never spread out
over wavelengths,
can never get out
of coherence with
the drive field.
And here, we have a
quantitative description
that at that moment,
we can obtain
spectroscopic information
about the resonance completely
unperturbed by motional effects.
Questions?
OK.
So that was maybe
the most fun part,
the extreme limit and
you realize what happens.
But now we want to sort
of fill in the gaps.
I first want to sort
of contrast what I just
described to you with a
semi-classical picture.
The semi-classical picture-- if
you have an emitting oscillator
or absorber and we have
electromagnetic plane wave,
we can now ask, what is
the phase of the plane wave
experienced by the atom?
And of course, the
phase is affected
by the motion of the
atom if we assume
the atom moves [INAUDIBLE]
with harmonic frequency omega
t and an amplitude x0.
Then this here is the
phase seen by the atom
in its own reference frame.
And if I then define-- with
another quotation mark,
because it's sort of something
which needs explanation.
If I define an instantaneous
frequency, which
is nothing else than the
derivative of the phase,
then I'll retrieve the
normal Doppler broadening.
So now you see where sort
of normal Doppler broadening
would come in.
But the question is, you
cannot measure an instantaneous
frequency.
It would violate
the Fourier theorem.
But if we can apply-- if the
atom oscillates slowly enough--
the motion is slow enough
that we can apply the concept
that we can look at the
frequency the atom experiences,
you would at least say, before
the atom changes its velocity,
it should see a few cycles.
If it oscillates fairly fast,
this concept, of course,
cannot be applied.
But at least you see where your
normal Doppler shift comes in.
It comes in in the concept of
an instantaneous frequency.
Of course, what we
should do now is
we should not take the concept
of the instantaneous frequency.
We should do rather
do it correctly.
What we have is we see we
have the phase of the atom.
So therefore, we
should-- by using
the motion of the atom
for x, we should have
formed Fourier transform.
The Fourier transform
tells us what
is the tonal spectrum
which the atom experiences.
So therefore, we
take this plane wave,
we put in the oscillatory
behavior of the atom,
and then we take away transform.
OK.
So the electromagnetic
field seen by the atom
is an amplitude which is
the cosine of the phase.
And the phase has a
temporal dependence
that's just the frequency
of the plane wave.
But now the precision
involves the oscillation
of the atom at the
[INAUDIBLE] frequency omega t.
And what I've introduced
here is the data [? vector ?]
is called the modulation index.
This is the relevant quantity.
It is k, which comes from
the plane wave, e to the ikr,
times the amplitude of the atom.
And so the modulation
index is nothing else
than the amplitude of the atomic
motion divided by the reduced
wavelengths of the light.
Just if you remember for a
second, this extreme stick
diagram where we had one big
stick and two smaller sticks,
remember, the intensity
in the smaller sticks
was the extension
of the atom divided
by the wavelength squared.
So we had exactly
the same parameter,
but the previous description
assumed a quantized picture
for the harmonic oscillator.
I really used a and a daggers
in the atomic wave function.
This is a semi-classical
picture where
I treat the
oscillation of the atom
in a classical description.
But in both cases, of course,
the relevant parameter
is the ratio over
which the atom moves--
the amplitude of
the atomic motion
or the size of the atomic
wave function in relation
to the wavelengths of the light.
OK.
So we want to Fourier
transform this function.
And this gives us the spectrum.
I can show you
that the result is
that we can have a Fourier
expansion of this amplitude,
and it involves basal functions.
So it is the basal
function Jm which tells us
what the intensity is
in the n's sideband.
And the argument of
the basal function,
whether we take the basal
function at the origin
or at a finite argument, is
given by beta modulation index.
You can't immediately
[INAUDIBLE] in just two lines.
We write the Fourier transform.
All you have to use
is those identities
which involve the
basal function.
Whenever you have the cosine
of a sine or the sine of a sine
and you Fourier
transform, you get,
naturally, basal functions.
OK.
So let's just look
at the result.
We talked about
the stick diagram.
The stick diagram was actually
motivated quantum mechanically.
But now we also find a stick
diagram purely classically
because of the periodic
motion in the harmonic trap.
But now what we obtain in
the semi-classical limit,
we obtain what is the
height of each stick.
Well, the height of the stick,
which is n sidebands away,
is given by the square of
the n's basal function.
And beta is the
modulation index.
And if beta goes
to 0, that means
the atom is not moving at all.
The amplitude x0 is 0.
This is the limit of
tight confinement.
Then all basal functions
are 0 except the 0's order.
And that means we are back
to a single delta function,
a single stick in
our stick diagram.
So let's now take the
result and discuss it.
So how does the
spectrum look like?
Well, I want to give you
two limits where the atom is
extended much larger
than the wavelengths.
This means large modulation
index beta and small modulation
index beta.
But first, in the limit where
beta is large-- for large beta,
the argument of
the basal function
becomes just cosine
beta minus phase.
So if we use that-- if we assume
a thermal distribution where
beta over kt d beta squared.
So we take our spectrum,
and we just convolute it
with a thermal distribution
of amplitudes x0, which
is, of course, just
the Boltzmann factor.
And in that limit, we
actually obtain a spectrum
where the envelope of the sticks
looks like the Doppler width.
So if those two
conditions are fulfilled,
then we obtain the
normal Doppler widths.
If, in addition, we assume
that the sidebands are not
resolved, because the
natural line width
is larger than the spacing.
So if we assume
that in addition,
then we just find
the normal Doppler
broadening how we have
derived it as in free space.
So normal Doppler
broadening is the limit
of the large modulation
index, a thermal distribution
of modulation index in the
case of not resolved sidebands.
The opposite limit,
of course, is
when beta is much
smaller than 1,
it means the amplitude of
the oscillating particle
is smaller than the wavelengths.
I mentioned it a few times,
so I should write it down.
This is the Lamb-Dicke regime.
And then the relevant
approximation
for the basal function
is in the limit.
And this limit is 1 over n
factorial times beta over 2 n.
And for the case that n
is 1, this is just beta.
And the amplitude
squared is beta squared.
It's x0 over lambda
squared, as we
had discussed before in
the quantum mechanic unit.
So you'll see that
to use matrix element
for the harmonic oscillator or
use a semi-classical Fourier
transformed with a basal
function, both lead
to the same result, that
deep in the Lamb-Dicke limit,
we have essentially three peaks.
And the satellites
are quadratically
small in the modulation
index squared.
So this regime is particularly
interesting for atomic locks
and for meteorological
applications
if the sidebands are resolved.
If the sidebands
are not resolved,
you have sort of a line
shape which depends,
let's say, on temperature,
because x0 squared,
if it's the thermal excitation,
is proportional to temperature.
So as you cool it
down, you will actually
see that your line
shape changes.
But the good thing is that
once you resolve the sidebands,
the line shape of
the central carrier
does not change anymore.
And once you can
resolve the sidebands,
you can just observe
the central carrier,
and you obtain
spectroscopic information
which is no longer blurred,
which is no longer affected
by motion or by temperature.
And that's, of course, a regime
where the atomic frequency
standards want to operate.
Questions?
OK.
Yes.
Let me just write that down,
because this is important.
For resolved sidebands,
you have sharp lines,
no motional broadening.
And the physics I
described to you
is actually analogous
to the Mossbauer effect.
In the Mossbauer effect, the
intensity of the recoil-less
emission of this recoil-less
line is described
by the [INAUDIBLE]
[? vector. ?] So in this case,
the [INAUDIBLE] [? vector ?]
is 1 minus the probability
for the two sidebands.
So the same concept of
Mossbauer line and [INAUDIBLE]
[? vector ?]
describes the physics
for tightly confined particles.
So if I use the analogy
to the Mossbauer effect,
the Mossbauer effect is called
the recoil-less emission
and absorption of x-rays.
So what we have here is we
have a recoil-less absorption
and emission of photons.
Of course, the photon which
is emitted and absorbed
has momentum.
There should be momentum recoil.
So the question is, where
does the momentum recoil
go when the confined
particle emits or absorbs
on the carrier of
the central line.
How do we reconcile
the result I derived
for you with momentum
conservation?
A trapped particle,
tightly confined.
And photon comes, has
momentum, the atom absorbs it.
But the spectrum does
not show any evidence
for recoil shifts and such.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: Must be absorbed
by the trap somehow.
PROFESSOR: Must be
absorbed by the trap, yes.
Your trap is anchored
in the laboratory.
And you transfer the momentum.
The atom is attached
to the trap.
The trap is attached
to the laboratory.
So the object which
takes over the momentum
is your whole apparatus
or, in the extreme case,
a whole building.
And there is, of
course, a kinetic energy
associated-- momentum
squared over 2 m.
But the mass is now the
mass of the building.
So therefore, there is
no energy associated
with absorbing the recoil.
So it is as if-- and this comes
back to some earlier remarks
I've made-- is
that when you have
this absorption in
the Lamb-Dicke regime
is it is as if your
two-level system has
an infinite mass behind it.
And that's sort of the situation
how I told you you should often
think about it,
you should separate
effects of the internal
degree of freedom
and the external
by just assuming
I can assume first
that the atom has infinite mass.
And once the atom
has infinite mass,
the motion degree of
freedom doesn't matter.
What I just explained to
you is a practical way
to endow your particle
with infinite mass.
Just connect it with type
confinement to your apparatus.
And then for the
momentum exchange,
there is a photon
field, it is actually
the mass of the whole
apparatus [INAUDIBLE].
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Is there
a more direct way
to think about this for maybe
the example of a magnetic trap,
the mechanism by which this
momentum is transferred?
Or absorbed.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Magnetic traps for
neutral particles
are usually not in
the Lamb-Dicke regime,
so you have to be a
little bit careful.
But the explanation
would be the same.
The magnetic fields
are like tight springs
which connect the neutral
atom to your coins.
And therefore, you
should just think
about the magnetic trap
in a mechanical model.
Your neutral atom is connected
to your coils with strings.
And if you now hit the
atom with a photon,
because of the quantization
of the discreteness
of this specturm, the
photon, in most cases,
does not have enough
recoil to create
a mechanical oscillation
of your particle.
The momentum goes
through the sphinx
to the support structure.
But occasionally,
with a probability
which is a modulation
index squared,
you will actually
promote the particle
to the first state
of harmonic motion.
And then the atom has
acquired some kinetic energy.
But this probability
can be made as small
as you want by going to a
smaller and smaller modulation
index.
That's the way how I
would think about it.
Nancy?
AUDIENCE: About
the multiple lines
that we get, I was wondering
if the levels of the harmonic
traps itself are blurred,
which could happen in the lab
if the trap depth is
moving, for example--
the levels of the trap
would get blurred.
Would that result in
additional broadening of this?
Or how would that affect?
PROFESSOR: It depends.
I think if you have some
temporal broadening, you know,
you just plug it into
your correlation function,
whatever shakes your system.
If that means the
atom sees some shaking
in the phase of the
electromagnetic field,
it affects it.
If you have an ensemble of atoms
or if you do the experiment
repeatedly, and your
measurements are the ensemble,
and every time you
do the measurement,
your magnetic trap has a
slightly different [INAUDIBLE],
and therefore, a slightly
different confinement, well,
what you would see is that
those sidebands fluctuate,
that the carrier is independent
of the trap frequency.
So therefore, the carrier is
actually the central peak--
would not be broadened
by fluctuations
in the harmonic confinement.
Let me just make one comment.
I derived the result for
you-- at least that one--
by taking the amplitude of the
atomic motion, the amplitude
of the phase, and doing
the Fourier analysis.
I mean, this is
exactly what we learned
from the formalism of
correlation function.
You should take the amplitude
of the perturbing field
and fully analyze it.
I didn't phrase it
here in the language
of correlation functions.
But what I did was exactly what
we learned from the correlation
function formalism.
OK.
Let me maybe summarize
in words what we learned.
So what we learned
from this discussion
is that what matters for
line broadening and obtaining
spectroscopic information
is the accumulated phase,
the phase which the
atom accumulates.
And if different
atoms in the ensemble
accumulate a phase which
is different by 2 pi,
at that moment, we
have reached what
we call the coherence time
of the correlation function.
And the inverse of this
time is a line broadening.
But now we also discussed the
case of tight confinement.
The atom can be in
very, very rapid motion.
And the phi dot,
the change of phase
can be very rapid due to
the instantaneous velocity.
But if the atom turns
around because it's
in a singulatory motion,
positive and negative Doppler
shifts completely
cancel, because you never
allow the atom, in this periodic
motion, to acquire a net phase.
And therefore, the motional
broadening is absent.
So one way to think
about this carrier
is that the atom rapidly
oscillates through plus kv
and minus kv Doppler shifts.
And the two cancel.
So this is the reason for that.
OK.
I think we are now very well
prepared for Dicke narrowing.
Actually, I have to say, it's
the first class this semester
that I was teaching a little
bit faster than I assumed.
So I'm now right at the end
what I prepared for today.
But I know my notes
sufficiently well
that I can go on for 10 minutes.
So the Dicke narrowing--
the last time I looked at it
was two years ago.
But let's get the
physical picture.
So I want to now apply
what we have learned
not to a trapped atom,
but to an atom which
is embedded in buffer gas.
So just think one
rubidium, or one sodium,
or one lithium atom.
And it is surrounded by a
buffer gas of argon or neon.
And I know sometimes when we
do saturation spectroscopy
to stabilize our lasers, we
have a little glass cell, which
has sodium or rubidium in it.
But we also put an argon
buffer gas into it.
So that's the situation
I want to describe now.
But Colin, you had a question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You wrote down the condition
for resolving the sidebands
as your trapped frequency being
larger than your natural line
width.
An alkalizer-- if you had,
say it were 10 megahertz line
width.
How do you actually resolve
this without a ridiculously--
because people do
sideband [INAUDIBLE],
and they don't have 10 megahertz
trap frequencies, do they?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So good question.
The question is, the
resolved sideband
limit, how can we reach it?
Well, it can be
reached in ion traps.
In ion traps, because you can
put kilovolts on electrodes,
you can really create harmonic
oscillator frequencies
which are many, many megahertz.
And then you are at the
resolved sideband limit,
assuming that the natural
lifetime, if that's the case,
of many ions is in the
megahertz [INAUDIBLE].
For neutral atoms,
it looks like, you
know, mission impossible.
However, there's a way out,
and this is the following.
One is you can maybe [INAUDIBLE]
one-dimensional optical latice.
So in the latices, you at
least have tight confinement
of many, many kilohertz.
But now you want to use
a very narrow transition.
If you use a very,
very narrow transition,
then even for 10 kilohertz
external harmonic oscillator
potential, [INAUDIBLE]
resolved sideband [INAUDIBLE].
Now, for alkalis, you
won't find an excited state
which has a natural line
width of 10 kilohertz.
And this will be our
discussion on Wednesday.
If you use a Raman
transition, we
go from one count state
with an off-resonant laser
to another ground
state, [INAUDIBLE]
will be two photon transitions.
But those two photons, since
there's no intermediate state,
can be regarded as, click-click,
you absorb two photons.
And in some picture--
that's a message
I will give you next week-- the
equivalent to a single photon.
So now you have a
two-photon transition,
which transfers
recall to the atom.
So the effective wavelengths
of the two-photon transition
is because you have
twice the photon energy.
You have two photons involved
which both have a recoil.
So the effective k vector is two
times the k vector of an atom.
But the spontaneous line
width is close to 0,
literally 0, because you
have a Raman transition
between two common states.
If you do Raman sideband
cooling of neutral atoms,
then you reach the
Lamb-Dicke limit,
you reach the limit
of strong confinement.
But you need a better
[INAUDIBLE] transition.
And there are, of
course, some atoms
which have a very
narrow clock transition.
But for many, many atoms which
have hyperfine structure,
you can resolve to
Raman transition.
OK.
Let's now talk about
Dicke narrowing.
So we have a situation that
we have an atom in buffer gas.
And in most situations, when
you put an atom into buffer gas,
you get what is called
collisional broadening.
I will talk about collisional
broadening on Friday.
Just a reminder, we have
class on Friday but not
on the following Monday.
So on Friday, we'll talk
about collisional broadening.
And I will discuss, for
instance, the model-- an atom
in the excited state, when it
collides, it gets de-excited.
And then you have
pretty much a situation
where you have, in effect,
a shortened lifetime
of the excited state.
And what you get is
a Lorentian which
is broader, which has a width
not of the natural line width,
but a width which
is [INAUDIBLE].
But there are
situations-- and that's
what I want to discuss
here-- that we have
atoms in a more
benign buffer gas.
Where we can assume that
this is actually fulfilled,
that collisions do not change.
Well, they're not de-exciting
the excited state.
But they're not even
changing the coherence
between counter-excited state.
So the phase evolution,
the internal state,
grounded excited
state just-- if you
can assume you have a Bloch
vector which oscillates,
and the Bloch vector
superposition [INAUDIBLE]
excited state oscillates
at the natural frequency,
and this Bloch
vector just rotates,
it doesn't have a hiccup,
it doesn't change its phase
when the atom collides
with the buffer gas atom.
So we assume that we have such
a buffer gas where collisions
don't change the
internal coherence.
And by internal coherence,
I mean the phase
between the ground state
and the excited state.
So in this situation--
but it's actually
a very important situation
which has been reached,
in many cases.
In this situation,
we have-- thus,
the buffer gas acts only on the
external motion of the atom.
And now you can
say, in some way,
the buffer gas acts like a trap.
The particle wants
to fly away, but it
collides with the
buffer gas atom.
And with a certain probability
or after a few collisions,
it returns back to the origin.
However, it's a lousy
trap, because there
is some randomness
and effusive motion.
So if you want to
describe it as a trap,
it would be a trap with a wide
spread of trap frequencies.
OK.
So if we use this
picture now, what
we have learned from
ion traps-- remember,
we had an ion trap
with a sharp carrier.
And then we had sidebands
at the trap frequency.
But if we have sort of
now a lousy trap which
each realization, each
moment has a different trap
frequency when
waving all my arms,
I would say for the other
part of the ensemble,
we get a carrier, and
we have something else.
And for another realization,
we have another trap frequency.
So if I use a little bit
of artistic intuition here,
I would expect, based
on what we learned
from the previous discussion,
that in such a buffer gas,
I would have a sharp
carrier, and then I
would have sort of
a pedestal, which
is the envelope of
many trap frequencies.
And we know sort of that the
envelope of all our sticks--
this was actually given
by the Doppler effect.
So what we may expect now
is that in this situation
with buffer gas, we
get a sharp line.
And then we have
this broad pedestal,
which you can think
[INAUDIBLE] intuitive picture
as smeared outside bands.
And I may call that
the Doppler pedestal.
And we would expect--
and I discussed that
with the basal
function, that there
is one limit where the
envelope of all those sticks
eventually looks like a
Doppler-broadened line.
Anyway, time is over.
But let me just give an outlook.
On Friday, what
I want to do is I
want to calculate the width
of this line with you.
And remember, all
we have to do is
we have to calculate the
correlation function.
Previously, when I derived
for you Doppler broadening,
the correlation function
was the kx becoming kvt.
kvt, where x became vt
how much the atom moves
with the velocity v.
By simply replacing the
linear motion, V times t,
with a diffusive model, we
can calculate the line shape.
And we will actually find
that the central line is not
infinitely sharp,
but it has a width
which is given by the
diffusion constant.
And if the diffusion
constant is very, very small,
we approach a very sharp line.
And the final comment is, and
this is called Dicke narrowing.
It is this
counterintuitive result
that collisions, if they
have those properties,
are not broadening the line.
They actually narrow the line
from the [INAUDIBLE] Doppler
width to something
which is much sharper.
And this has been useful for
high precision spectroscopy.
But I think with the concept
which we discussed today
of confinement, you realize
why collisions can actually
reduce the line widths,
namely by preventing
the atoms from acquiring
random phases with respect
to the drive field [INAUDIBLE].
Any questions?
So see you on Friday
in this other building,
this other lecture
hall that's just
been announced on the website.